Алло!
Люба?
Люба, вже бусик приїхав.
Бусик приїхав вже!
Ну де, до тебе.
А де ти є?
Христос Воскрес!
Воістину Воскрес!
Взагалі-то, Христос Воскрес!
— Так? Ну Слава Богу!
— Якщо по цьому календарю.
— Сьогодні Пасха!
— Якби ноги не боліли, я би...
Сьогодні Пасха, вона може бути...
Стій, я краще так зачеплюся...
— Ой... Христос Воскрес!
— Воістину Воскрес!
Гей, Галя!
Добрий ранок!
— Добрий ранок!
— Христос Воскрес!
Воістину Воскрес!
Так, все!
Прямо їдемо в церкву.
Зміївку знають як село,
де живуть німці, шведи,
українці, бойки, поляки.
Особливість Зміївки в тому,
що це, фактично, єдине село...
Шведи тільки у Зміївці.
Збереглася старошведська мова.
І шведи, і ми так трошки їх...
Можна сказати, підтримуємо
усі разом, спільнотою.
Це маленька Європа на півдні України.
[сміється]
Ми зараз прямуємо
до шведської кірхи Йоханська.
Сьогодні це православна церква України.
Церква почала будуватися 1882 року.
Шведи були за віросповіданням лютерани,
які прибули до Зміївки
з острова Даґо 1782 року 1 травня.
Добрий день!
[ведуть нечутну розмову]
— Що у вас там, все нормально?
— Та нічого, потихеньку.
— Завтра Пасха?
— Так.
— Завтра Пасха, шведська.
Шведська, німецька,
польська і трохи українська.
[сміється]
Це моя сестра двоюрідна.
Поштарка.
[сміється]
Зараз ми перебуваємо
на подвір'ї церкви.
Бачимо, що є встановлений пам'ятний знак
заснування села шведами.
Коли вони прибули на територію
сучасної Зміївки,
то тут вони побачили Дніпро.
Вода, рибалки.
Тут був у нас на зимівнику в Зміївці
козак на прізвище Плоскоголовий.
І в нього було ще 30 козаків,
які працювали в нього.
Ці козаки допомагали шведам
облаштовуватися на цій землі.
Ми зараз прийшли до родини
Валентини Василишин з роду Герман.
І завтра у нас Пасха католицька.
І вони готуються до Пасхи.
Валентина вже напекла
таких гарних пасочок.
Ми бачимо на столі велике яєчко.
Так, це мені шведи подарували.
Колись я була в Швеції,
це мені шведи подарували.
Це на Пасху…
У них теж у Швеції тут свічечка.
І коли запалюєш її сюди,
тут відображення йде таке...
От у Зміїівці відсвятковується
і Андрія, і Люсії, і святий Миколай.
Потім католицьке Різдво 25 грудня.
Ми святкуємо,
у Зміївці вже святкують.
А потім знову…
У Зміївці два Різдва, дві Пасхи,
так що все добре.
А отакий прапор у мене є ось…
Це нам подарували у Швеції, Ян.
Це коли приїжджають шведи,
ми вивішуємо у дворі їм.
І їм здалека видно,
що тут шведська родина.
Шведська родина, так.
От бачите, дуже гарний.
Кольори Швеції і України співпадають,
так що нормально.
І в нас на нашому зміївському прапорі
і гербі також кольори жовто-блакитні.
Села мають старі назви, як-от Шланґендорф,
Мюльґаузендорф, Ґаммальсвенскбю і Клостердорф.
У перекладі це була Зміївка,
Михайлівка, Вербівка і Костирка.
Десь балкою розділяються,
десь — об'їзною дорогою.
Але це одне велике село Зміївка.
Коли прибули шведи,
вони заснували старошведське Ґаммальсвенскбю.
А потім згодом прибувають
з Лютерберга німці-лютерани.
І засновують село Шланґендорф.
Шланген була притока Дніпра,
яка мала змієвидний вигляд,
die Schlange — змія.
Ось бачите, дивіться,
яка фотографія, це стара-стара.
Це мої бабуся, дідусь
і батько мій, маленький ще.
Моя мама народилася тут уже.
У 1929 році вона була також в Швеції,
коли оце корабель приїжджав
і забирав їх усіх.
І мої бабусі, дідусі —
вони також були у Швеції.
А потому…
Важко було там їм.
Старошведської мови
вже наче як там не було.
А нову наші не знали.
Вона трохи відрізняється,
десь якісь слова є схожі,
але загалом вона відрізняється.
То вони...
Кажуть: «Дуже нам було важко».
І вони вирішили,
що їм краще вернутися назад.
Зі мною по сусідству жив
Анас Густав Густавич.
Казав, що коли прийшла
радянська влада, 1929 рік,
вони мали свою церкву,
мали свою сільську раду.
А в сільській раді документація вся
велася на старошведській мові.
Нова влада прийшла,
і почали утискати їх.
Закривати церкву.
Не розмовляти старошведською мовою.
Не підтримувати свої традиції.
А людям це ж не подобалося.
Сюди приплив пароплав,
до берегів Дніпра.
Вони з клунками вантажаться
на цей корабель,
покидаючи цю рідну землю,
де вони вже жили.
Вже століття пройшло
фактично й більше.
То, загалом, було тяжко покидати,
вони не хотіли.
От Густаву Густавичу
тоді було буквально...
Він з 1922 року,
це було йому сім років.
Хто мав трошки більше грошей,
то залишився у Швеції.
Інші повернулись у Зміївку.
А ще одна частина шведів
зміївських поїхала до Канади.
Тому нащадки зміївських шведів є і на Ґотланді
зараз у Швеції, є в Канаді і у Зміївці.
А 1939 року почалася
Друга світова війна.
Радянська влада збагнула,
що у Зміївці проживають німці і шведи,
які можуть потім співпрацювати
з німецькою окупацією.
І вони їх почали виселяти до Сибіру.
У СРСР: Комі, Казахстан.
Хтось в Німеччину поїхав.
І вони вже поверталися в 1950-х роках,
коли в село були примусово переселені
українці із Західної України.
[старошведською]
♪ Ти — найкраще, що я знаю, ♪
♪ Ти — найдорожче у світі, ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Ти як зірки, як вітри, як хвилі, ♪
♪ Як птахи, як квіти на землі! ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Ти моя дороговказна зірка і друг, ♪
♪ Ти моя віра, моя надія, моя любов, ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Ти моя кров і мої легені, мої очі, ♪
♪ Мої плечі, мої руки і моє серце! ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Свобода — твоє прекрасне ім'я, ♪
♪ Дружба — твоя горда мати, ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Справедливість — твій брат, мир — твоя сестра, ♪
♪ Боротьба — твій батько, майбутнє — твоя відповідальність! ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Ти — найкраще, що я знаю, ♪
♪ Ти — найдорожче у світі... ♪
Я з родини бойків,
які були примусово переселені
на Херсонщину.
1951 року.
Я народився уже в Зміївці.
Ми по сусідству жили
зі шведською сім'єю.
Там було багато дітей, мої друзі.
Їхні родичі розмовляли
на старошведській мові.
Діти розуміли цю мову,
але не розмовляли цією мовою,
тому що в період радянської влади
було якось соромно,
тому що була така політика
розмовляти російською мовою.
Ми сьогодні бачимо, що для того,
щоб показати свою культуру,
треба зробити якийсь фестиваль.
А вони в родинах зберігали це все:
вони співали свої старошведські пісні,
вони мали книжки,
казочки дітям розповідали.
Це не було так на загал.
Шведи розмовляли українською мовою,
тому що прибуття українців
із Західної України...
Вони, можна сказати,
асимілювалися в українство.
Було таке дружнє ставлення
між ними, між цими народами.
Тому що традиції подібні.
Вони пережили свої лихоліття,
а українці — свої лихоліття.
Вони спілкувалися,
знаходили спільну мову...
Доля українців, доля шведів
і німців однакова була.
Оці життєві перипетії,
які вони пережили,
вони потім переносили,
вже спілкувалися між собою, радилися.
І був спільний ворог їхній.
[старошведською]
♪ Шведська мова і ... ♪
♪ Що я маю на батьківщині, ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Серед усіх мов світу ♪
♪ Ні на що не проміняю дорогі шведські слова! ♪
[старошведською] Щастя вам,
Марія, Анна, Валентина,
[старошведською] та вашим родинам,
дітям, онукам, всього доброго!
[старошведською] Нехай щастить і усього доброго!
[старошведською] Дуже дякую! Тобі теж!
Це було по-шведськи привітання з Пасхою.
Вона побажала нам всім
здоров'я міцного, дітям, всій родині.
І я їй сказала так само:
«Дякую, і тобі».
У період незалежної України
ця відлига стала кращою.
Є можливість мігрувати.
І почали їздити сюди шведи першими.
І вони побачили, як живуть тут
старошведи, як працюють вони,
як працює загалом народ у Зміївці,
який проживає [тут].
Їм сподобалося,
краєвиди дуже сподобалися.
І коли пішло відродження храмів,
розбудова їхня,
вони ще побачили,
що це більше розвивається.
Дуже часто багато приїжджає людей
похилого віку, яким за 70-80 років.
Їхнє десь дитинство [минало],
або їхні родичі проживали тут у Зміївці.
Їм було цікаво побачити ті оселі,
в яких жили їхні пращури.
[англійською] Під час мого першого
літа тут це було моє улюблене місце.
[англійською] Літній душ.
[англійською] У Швеції в нас немає
літніх душів, бо не так багато сонця.
[англійською] О, це було прекрасно!
[англійською] Я обробляю землю
навколо Зміївки.
[англійською] Ми почали 2010 року.
[англійською] Минулого року я сіяв
пшеницю, ячмінь та жито.
[англійською] Мені дуже-дуже
подобається соняшник.
[англійською] Тому я готуюсь
сіяти його багато.
[англійською] Це так гарно,
бачите, як гарно.
[англійською] Блакитне і жовте,
звичайно, як ваш прапор.
[англійською] Мені подобається
така місцевість.
Король тут і королева.
Село не просто готувалось,
тут воно гуділо.
І коли король приїжджав,
ми біля церкви також зустрічали його.
Ну, там була програма ціла:
одні зустрічали на дорозі,
а потім уже в церкві
ми співали пісню.
І він приходив, вітався з нами,
з кожним за руку.
Візит короля в Україну відбувся
вперше в історії взагалі.
2009 року.
Він хотів почути старошведську мову
у Зміївці, яка зникла у Швеції.
Він це почув.
Він побачив і навіть просльозився,
коли був з візитацією у Зміївці.
Ми ще малі були.
Почали приїжджати такі туристи:
на один день, на дві годинки
приїхали, побули.
І це була в нас шведська сім'я.
Там було дві бабусі старенькі.
Вони спілкувались.
І коли наші бабусі хотіли,
наприклад, поспілкуватися,
вони сходилися там у цій родині,
родині Мальмас.
Вони співали там пісні.
І після того почали шведи
приїжджати туди.
Ось, навіть тут фотографія є.
Старенька бабуся, оце вони
в Мальмасі́в там були.
І це бачите — стіл,
накритий прямо у дворі,
оце вони так приїжджали.
І вони прямо в дворі ставили
великий, довгий стіл.
І вони там пили каву,
бутерброди [їли].
І таке спілкування в них.
А потім вони їхали звідси, то...
Дуже вони любили
наші херсонські кавуни.
У нас тут були
дуже смачні кавуни великі.
І коли вони грузили собі в автобус,
то там такі кавуни.
Вони казали: «Нам нічого не треба,
нам побільше кавунів,
щоб можна було кавунів наїстись,
саме херсонських».
Згодом почала викладатися
шведська мова тут у школі.
Почали діти ходить.
У мене дочка навіть ходила,
також вивчала шведську мову.
А потім навіть була в Швеції,
і зустрічалася з дідусем моїм, своїм прадідом.
[англійською] І я люблю персик.
[англійською] У Швеції ми не маємо
персиків — це дуже-дуже смачно.
[англійською] Мій перший візит
до України був 2008 року.
[англійською] Як турист відвідав
Каховку та Чумак, а також Зміївку.
[англійською] Старі шведські жінки
співали для нас у старій шведській церкві.
[англійською] Потім ми обідали в…
Ми називаємо це «пабом».
[англійською] Я був вражений.
[англійською] Спершу, з автобуса,
я побачив горизонт на тисячу кілометрів,
[англійською] де ніщо не оброблялося.
[англійською] А потім — побачив
Швецію в селі в Україні.
[англійською] О, я цього не помічав раніше.
[старошведською]
♪ Ти древня, ти вільна, ти гориста північ, ♪
♪ Ти мовчазна, ти радісна і прекрасна! ♪
[старошведською]
♪ Вітаю тебе, найпрекрасніша країно на землі, ♪
♪ Твоє сонце, твоє небо, твої луки зелені! ♪
[старошведською]
Коли шведи приїжджали, наприклад,
бабусі спілкуються з ними, говорять,
а ми збоку стоїмо,
просто дивимось на них.
На нас навіть уваги
дуже ніхто не звертав.
Ну, що, молоді, стоять там,
чи діти, чи підлітки.
Уже бабусь стало менше,
бабусям стало важче співати.
І вони почали вже нас підгукувати,
що давайте, вчіться, помагайте,
тому що нас не стане — хто буде?
Ну, як я казала,
ми тепер стали бабусями.
[сміється]
І ми тепер «гвоздь програми»,
називається.
Це буде музей старошведської громади.
І це буде шведська селянська хата.
Це свого роду музей.
Історія заснування села Зміївки.
Коли я був на Ґотланді,
є також селянська хата, шведська садиба.
Там також [є] ця історія села Зміївки.
Це все життя їхнє і до сьогодні.
Ми плануємо створити на базі шведської садиби
музей «Бойківська садиба».
Тобто будинок, де проживали шведи,
це родове дерево цієї родини.
Але з бойківським ґатунком.
Тобто поєднання двох культур:
шведської й української, бойківської.
Це буде цікаво.
Ми історію поважаємо
і хочемо творити цю історію.
І, таким чином, відкрився екскурсійно-туристичний
маршрут «Дорогами маленької Європи».
І туристи почали їздити
не тільки з-за кордону,
а почали їздити і зі всієї України.
А ще й кухня — українська, шведська, німецька.
Так що тут можна посмакувати.
Українці зберігають свої звичаї й обряди.
І, загалом, є такий гурт «Бойківчани»,
яким цікаво, які зберегли
свої традиції, наспіви.
[сміються]
[старошведською]
Ми веселі музиканти з села Старошведське.
Тобто ми веселі музиканти зі старошведського села.
Ми перейняли від старошведських бабусь.
То бабусі співали.
А ми вивчили,
взяли в репертуар.
Ми супроводжували,
тепер самі співаємо.
Написали слова українськими буквами.
[сміються]
[cпівають старошведською]
♪ співають пісню «Перелаз» ♪
Шведи і люблять сторони українства,
а українці і сторони шведської
також люблять оці всі моменти.
І повчитися,
і поєднати це добре, файно.
От беремо сьогоднішню нашу Зміївку —
тут багато національностей.
І багато культур, мов,
традицій, обрядів, звичаїв.
І тому ось така має бути Україна.
Це Європа.
Україна — це Європа.
[cпівають старошведською]
♪ співають пісню «Перелаз» ♪